I could talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother.
我可以谈论几个小时关于我如何遇见你母亲的每一件事。
And we do!
我们做到了！
But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
但当谈到我自己的健康时，我却一无所知。
I'd shrug off low energy, or a fitness plateau as just stress.
我会把低能量或健身平台期视为压力而忽视。
Basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website you can choose from a suite of more than 100 health tests, including micronutrient allergy, testosterone, fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从 100 多项健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online, then visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试，然后访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
With in days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
几天之内，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
For your journey, visit ondemand.labcore.com-mother and use code Mother to save up to 15% on select tests.
对于您的旅程，请访问 ondemand.labcore.com-mother 并使用代码 Mother 在精选测试中节省高达 15% 的费用。
That's ondemand.labcore.com-mother and use code Mother.
这是 ondemand.labcore.com-mother 并使用代码 Mother。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
As a young adult, finding the right path to your future can feel overwhelming.
作为一个年轻人，找到通往未来的正确道路可能会让人感到不知所措。
It starts with year-up United's tuition-free job training program, Career Pathways.
它始于美联航的免学费职业培训计划“职业道路”。
If you're without a bachelor's degree but have a high school diploma or GED, you can get skills first training to succeed in the industries you're passionate about, all while earning a weekly educational stipend to offset basic expenses.
如果您没有学士学位，但拥有高中文凭或 GED，您可以获得技能优先培训，以便在您热衷的行业中取得成功，同时每周赚取教育津贴来抵消基本费用。
From there, you'll have access to internships and hands-on experiences with Fortune 500 companies, With year up, United's job placement services and personalized coaching and mentorship, you can put your knowledge, skills, and most importantly, confidence into practice.
从那里，您将有机会在财富 500 强公司实习并获得实践经验。随着一年的时间，美联航的就业安置服务以及个性化辅导和指导，您可以将您的知识、技能，以及最重要的是，信心付诸实践。
Apply to year up, United today.
今天就申请加入曼联。
And take the first step toward achieving the career you want.
并迈出实现您想要的职业的第一步。
Visit yearup.org to learn more.
访问yearup.org 了解更多信息。
Then he turned to us and was like, come in on Monday and you're hired.
然后他转向我们说，周一来，你就被录用了。
And we walked out and we're so stunned that we got lost in the complex L-shaped floor plan of the toes and no way to get lost, but we got lost.
我们走出去，惊呆了，我们在脚趾复杂的L形平面图中迷路了，没有办法迷路，但我们迷路了。
All the way down the hall, we turned the only corner, the only corner of the whole hallway.
沿着走廊一路走下去，我们拐过唯一的拐角，整个走廊唯一的拐角。
And we turned the corner and like you can film this in your mind, it's high noon and there at the other end is David Letterman.
我们转过拐角，就像你可以在脑海中拍摄这一切一样，当时是正午，而另一端是大卫·莱特曼。
Like standing alone, like I think he was like tossing a football, just standing there like he's maybe gonna kick our ass or something and we say to him, do you know where the elevator is?
就像一个人站着，我觉得他就像扔一个足球，站在那里，好像他可能会踢我们的屁股什么的，我们对他说，你知道电梯在哪里吗？
It's Josh Rander, welcome to a bonus episode of how we made your mother.
我是乔什·兰德尔，欢迎收看我们如何造就你母亲的额外剧集。
We heard the tale of how Craig and Carter came to write, how I met your mother, but there's an even deeper, richer backstory, how Craig met Carter.
我们听说了克雷格和卡特如何开始写作，我如何遇见你母亲的故事，但还有更深刻、更丰富的背景故事，克雷格如何遇见卡特。
And we're gonna get into this twisty, windy mystery right now.
我们现在就要进入这个曲折多风的谜团。
I want to get first the origin story of how you two met Carter and Craig or Craig and Carter.
我想先了解你们两个如何认识卡特和克雷格或克雷格和卡特的起源故事。
It's really Carter and Craig tell us how you guys met and what were your first impressions of each other.
卡特和克雷格确实告诉我们你们是如何认识的以及你们对彼此的第一印象是什么。
I'm just curious.
我只是好奇。
If you remember the moment you met each other, I don't remember.
如果你记得你们相遇的那一刻，我不记得了。
I don't remember us meeting.
我不记得我们见过面。
We were sort of both part of the part of the furniture at Wesleyan for a good year and a half.
我们在卫斯理安大学度过了美好的一年半时间。
I think before we actually like had a conversation, I remember Craig played drums.
我想在我们真正喜欢交谈之前，我记得克雷格打鼓。
made him a very, like, very, uh, in demand commodity in the, in the music world.
让他成为音乐界非常、非常、呃、非常抢手的商品。
I was like a singer and guitarist and not very good at either.
我就像一名歌手和吉他手，但两者都不是很擅长。
So like, I wanted to be in a band really bad and, uh, no one was taking and Craig was in, like, seven bands.
所以就像，我非常想加入一支乐队，但是，呃，没有人接受，而克雷格参加了大约七个乐队。
I think he had a prom set and he could play and he was really good.
我认为他有一场舞会演出，他可以演奏，而且他真的很棒。
And, uh, yeah, that was so that we sort of, like, but like English classes.
而且，呃，是的，我们有点喜欢英语课。
I think, I think we were in the some, like, English, like short story writing classes and, uh, some, uh, like, at screenwriting classes, and just sort of eyeballed each other from across the, across the conference table.
我想，我想我们在一些，比如，英语，比如短篇小说写作课上，还有，呃，一些，呃，比如，在剧本写作课上，我们只是在会议桌对面互相注视着对方。
I'm going to create a hit TV show with that guy one day, I just had a feeling.
有一天我要和那个人一起制作一部热门电视节目，我只是有一种预感。
Yeah.
是的。
First of all, Carter is under selling his singing prowess.
首先，卡特正在推销他的歌唱实力。
He was an end of it.
他是这一切的终结者。
Like once you actually got on there and sang everyone was like, wait a second, let's get that.
就像有一次你真的上场唱歌，每个人都会说，等一下，让我们开始吧。
Like then you would then the tables turned.
就像那时你就会扭转局面。
No one gave a shit about the drummer anymore.
没有人再关心鼓手了。
So I just want to make that very clear.
所以我只想说得非常清楚。
I tried, someone heard me hollering in the showers and that was it.
我尝试过，有人听到我在淋浴时大喊大叫，仅此而已。
Was there a moment when you guys made each other laugh for you, you, you started thinking comedically?
有没有那么一瞬间，你们让彼此为你而笑，你，你开始用喜剧的方式思考？
I remember we were in a screenwriting class together.
我记得我们一起上编剧课。
I feel like before we were really friends, what really made us friends is playing in a band together.
我觉得在我们成为真正的朋友之前，真正让我们成为朋友的是一起在乐队里演奏。
We finally got in a band together a junior year, right, Carter?
我们终于在大三的时候组建了一支乐队，对吧，卡特？
And then we're in bands together the whole second half of college and to this day are we still playing in a band together.
然后我们整个大学后半段都在乐队里，直到今天我们仍然一起在乐队里演奏。
I was very much our first way we worked together was playing in a band but we weren't close because Carter was the lead singer.
我们第一次合作是在乐队中演奏，但我们关系并不亲密，因为卡特是主唱。
We were in a nine piece soul band with like four horns and I was behind a drum set.
我们在一个九人灵魂乐队中，有四个号角，我在鼓组后面。
Carter, you mean in this band scene?
卡特，你是说在这个乐队场景中吗？
We barely had a conversation.
我们几乎没有交谈。
It was fun.
很有趣。
It was really true.
这确实是真的。
Like seven is like, I feel like that's that's conservative.
就像七一样，我觉得那是保守的。
I think we got upwards of like 12.
我想我们大概有 12 个以上。
It was like the size of like a, like a early 2006, the polyphonic spree, it was a whole full choir.
它的规模就像2006年初的复调狂欢，它是一个完整的合唱团。
Yeah, I think we had like two rows of risers.
是的，我想我们有两排立管。
You know, it was it was a lot of people.
你知道，当时有很多人。
So we didn't really Yeah, we didn't it was like the real moment.
所以我们真的没有，是的，我们没有，这就像真正的时刻。
I feel like was MTV we we Kreg and I got a We played in this band together all junior year And then I feel like the way I retell this story and maybe this is true or maybe this is apocryphal But like maybe we didn't know each didn't know that the other was applying to this internship But then we showed up in in New York City like we went in for like like on a weekday and in sometime in the spring of I guess it would be 1996 to both to interview for an internship at MTV to in their development department, which we didn't, I don't think we even knew what development meant.
我感觉就像是 MTV，我们 Kreg 和我整个大三都在这个乐队里一起演奏然后我感觉就像我重述这个故事的方式，也许这是真的，也许这是杜撰的但也许我们不知道彼此不知道对方正在申请这份实习但后来我们出现在纽约，就像我们在一个工作日一样，在春天的某个时候我想那是 1996 年，两人都去面试实习从 MTV 到他们的开发部门，我们没有，我认为我们甚至不知道开发意味着什么。
I thought like are we like hanging photographs on the screen?
我想我们是不是喜欢在屏幕上挂照片？
We were like plus there's never going to be an era where MTV does anything but play music videos.
我们当时想，永远不会有一个 MTV 除了播放音乐视频之外什么都不做的时代。
So what kind of shows are they going to play?
那么他们会表演什么样的节目呢？
So wait, so this was between your junior and senior year?
那么等等，这是你大三和大四之间的事情吗？
Yes.
是的。
So then I know that you guys, by the time you graduated, is it true you had like a comedy packet together, just the two of you?
那么我知道你们，当你们毕业的时候，你们真的像一个喜剧包一样，只有你们两个吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
We started writing that summer.
那年夏天我们开始写作。
That summer working at MTV.
那年夏天在 MTV 工作。
And again, that was after a year of being in a band at some point during which Carter was like, I think there's a drummer back there behind some of those horn players.
再说一次，那是在乐队呆了一年之后的某个时候，卡特就像是，我认为在一些喇叭手后面有一个鼓手。
And I was like, I'm like, trackers.
我就像，我就像，追踪者。
He looks like the guy that sings the songs.
他看起来就像那个唱歌的人。
We were just like, no, we weren't close in the band because the band was 45 people.
我们当时就想，不，我们在乐队中的关系并不亲密，因为乐队有 45 人。
But we then, we really bonded at MTV, but we'd also already had a screenwriting class and I'll embarrass Carter again by saying, first of all, he was a great singer and he was very in demand to be a singer.
但后来我们在 MTV 上真正建立了联系，但我们也已经上了编剧课，我会再次让卡特感到尴尬，首先，他是一位伟大的歌手，而且非常需要他成为一名歌手。
And second, he was in a screenwriting class with me and he was the best fucking writer.
其次，他和我一起上编剧课，他是最棒的编剧。
Well, I wanted you, I wanted you, but you, Carter was like, his writing so stood out in the screenwriting class.
好吧，我想要你，我想要你，但是你，卡特就像，他的写作在编剧班上如此突出。
It's just like a dinky little, right?
它就像一个小东西，对吧？
Like 10 or 12 people, we sort of volunteered scenes.
就像 10 或 12 个人一样，我们是自愿参与场景的。
And you were like the only person cobbling together, using it to cobble together a feature-length script.
你就像是唯一一个拼凑的人，用它拼凑出一个长篇剧本。
And I just remember going like, the balls on this fucking guy.
我只记得当时的感觉，就是对这个该死的家伙的蛋蛋。
Oh, right.
哦，对了。
But with admiration, I was like, this guy, right?
但带着钦佩之情，我想，这家伙，对吗？
You were putting, I remember what the script was.
你说的，我记得剧本是什么。
I remember it was good.
我记得那是好的。
It was insane and like funny and violent.
这很疯狂，既有趣又暴力。
It was like, it was like, it wasn't a crazy guy.
就像，就像，这不是一个疯子。
Heather's ish.
希瑟是这样的。
I feel like you told me that there was a lot of buzz about Carter before he even got to school because he had a play being produced off Broadway and he was late for school.
我感觉你告诉我卡特在上学之前就已经有很多关于他的传闻了，因为他在百老汇正在制作一部戏剧，而他上学迟到了。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
That is true.
确实如此。
Yes, I had a play that I wrote.
是的，我有一部自己写的戏剧。
I was really into playwriting in high school, like just fell in love with theater and I wrote a few short plays and on a whim, just sent one of them into the New York Young Playwrights Festival, which was like a big contest.
我在高中时非常喜欢剧本创作，就像爱上了戏剧一样，我写了一些短剧，一时兴起，只是将其中一部送入了纽约青年剧作家节，这就像一场大型比赛。
At the time, it was a, it was a big, I mean, this is before YouTube.
当时，这是一个，这是一个大，我的意思是，这是在 YouTube 之前。
It was back when like, there was no like, you know, you had to like physically print something out and send it out to New York for any chance of anyone ever seeing it, you know.
那时候，没有类似的东西，你知道，你必须喜欢打印一些东西并将其发送到纽约，以便任何人有机会看到它，你知道。
So it was a, I just sent this thing in and it ended up winning and the prize was a two month production of my show as part of a night of one acts at young, at playwright's horizons theater in New York, which I later found out like, oh, that's actually a really good theater.
所以，我刚刚把这个东西寄了进去，它最终获胜了，奖品是我的节目为期两个月的制作，作为年轻表演之夜的一部分，在纽约剧作家的地平线剧院，我后来发现，哦，那实际上是一个非常好的剧院。
It's kind of, it was a big deal.
有点，这是一件大事。
And the play was directed by Michael Mayer.
该剧由迈克尔·梅尔执导。
Yeah.
是的。
I always find this amazing.
我总是觉得这很神奇。
At what age did you say I want to write things?
你说我几岁想写东西？
I want to write plays.
我想写戏剧。
I want to write movies.
我想写电影。
I think it was like, I'm going to say I was 14.
我想这就像，我想说我14岁。
I was really into watching stuff.
我真的很喜欢看东西。
Like I just was a voracious consumer of television and movies and, you know, it was the golden age of video stores.
就像我是电视和电影的贪婪消费者一样，你知道，那是音像店的黄金时代。
And so I had a bunch of friends who were really into like zombie movies and stuff.
所以我有一群非常喜欢僵尸电影之类的朋友。
And like I, but then it was actually, uh, it was a, I took a trip to the library, the public library, which my, my first time out to libraries.
就像我一样，但实际上，呃，这是一个，我去了图书馆，公共图书馆，这是我第一次去图书馆。
I found out there was a book called, uh, how to write a movie in 21 days by, um, and remember, I, I think it was Vicki King was maybe the name.
我发现有一本书叫做，呃，如何在 21 天内写一部电影，嗯，记住，我，我想这可能是 Vicki King 的名字。
I can't remember the person who wrote it, but it's the, it's the book that changed my life.
我不记得是谁写的，但就是这本书改变了我的生活。
It was like a little slim, a little volume stuck between, in like their film section of the Shaker Heights Public Library, but it, like, I was like, oh, right of film, you can do that.
它就像一个薄薄的、夹在中间的小卷，就像沙克高地公共图书馆的电影区一样，但它，就像，我当时想，哦，电影的右边，你可以做到这一点。
Right.
正确的。
I guess films get written.
我猜电影是写出来的。
Someone has to, like, write down on paper what the actor's going to say.
必须有人在纸上写下演员要说的话。
And that just, like, kicked the door down.
这就像把门踢开了一样。
And after that, I'm going to write screenplays.
之后，我会写剧本。
Do you ever find it astonishing, like, I always think a 15-year-old teenager decided what I was going to do for my life?
你有没有觉得很惊讶，比如，我总是认为一个 15 岁的青少年决定了我一生要做什么？
Just like, how astonishing that is, like, a 14-year-old boy.
就像，这是多么令人惊讶，就像一个14岁的男孩一样。
That's said, you're going to be a writer.
也就是说，你将成为一名作家。
I feel like, do you know the show Passing Strange by Stu?
我觉得，你知道 Stu 的《Passing Strange》吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Yeah.
是的。
He has a line like that.
他有这样的台词。
It's kind of the same thing.
这是一样的事情。
Yeah, it's like this, this ding dong who doesn't know anything about anything is, but having some sort of like the life visionary, almost prophetic sense of like, this is a good idea.
是啊，就是这样，这个什么都不懂的叮咚，但是有某种像人生的憧憬，近乎预言般的感觉，这是一个好主意。
We should do this impossible thing.
我们应该做这件不可能的事。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was absolutely right in all of our cases, that is what we were supposed to be doing.
在我们所有的情况下，这都是绝对正确的，这就是我们应该做的。
You know, it's funny about reminiscing about college because Alec Lavar, producer extraordinaire went to Wesleyan with us, me and Carter, and I often feel like Josh went to Wesleyan because he played the guy who went to Wesleyan on how I met your mother.
你知道，回忆大学很有趣，因为出色的制片人亚历克·拉瓦尔（Alec Lavar）和我们、我和卡特一起去了卫斯理安，我经常觉得乔什去了卫斯理安，因为他在我如何认识你母亲的故事中扮演了那个去卫斯理安的人。
I mean, forget that you did Rex.
我的意思是，忘记你做了雷克斯。
We still don't know.
我们仍然不知道。
No, he, he was just disguised as that directs the whole thing.
不，他，他只是伪装成整个事情的指挥者。
That's why we didn't know.
这就是为什么我们不知道。
Well, a lot of Wesleyan grads think I went to Wesleyan.
嗯，很多卫斯理学院的毕业生都认为我去了卫斯理学院。
It really feels like even to me, it feels like kind of like I'd like to still petition for my honorary degree.
甚至对我来说，感觉就像是我仍然想申请我的荣誉学位。
You should totally get one.
你完全应该得到一个。
Yeah, it feels like it's New Yorker who went to Wesleyan.
是的，感觉就像是纽约人去了卫斯理安。
It very much feels that way, but I would have been like Carter and Ohio and who went to Wesley.
感觉很像这样，但我会像卡特和俄亥俄州一样，他们去了韦斯利。
Exactly.
确切地。
Yeah.
是的。
So hiring and sort of wearing the costume of a New Yorker.
所以雇用并穿着纽约人的服装。
Yeah, that's right.
是的，没错。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
Did you read the post today?
今天的帖子你读了吗？
Steinbrunner.
斯坦布伦纳。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child, a baby in the house, you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我有一个孩子了，家里有一个婴儿，你知道我觉得做什么很难吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
Yes, that's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
是的，这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know.
我知道。
And I forget.
我忘了。
Oh, I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog, and myself.
哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So how are we going to solve that problem?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something just quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，我不会，没有必要，不用大惊小怪。
You know, I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
你知道，我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes, and so what would solve that problem?
是的，那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, wait, are you talking about...
哦，等等，你是在说……
are you talking about Bavarian meat slow lamb yager snacks tics we agreed that's what right before we started talking to so we said that's what we're going to talk about well this is what i want to talk about the great tasting Bavarian meat little lamb yager snacks tics they sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life which is i forget to uh...
你在谈论巴伐利亚肉慢羊肉雅格零食抽动症吗？我们同意这就是我们开始交谈之前的内容，所以我们说这就是我们要讨论的内容，这就是我想谈论美味的巴伐利亚肉小羊肉雅格零食抽动症，他们给我们送了一些这些，它们很美味，它们解决了我生活的核心问题，那就是我忘记了呃...
to eat uh...
吃饭呃...
there they're naturally fermented they're made with real ingredients slow smoked for bold flavor packed with nine grams of protein per serving and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们在那里自然发酵，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also, I have a 19 year old boy, also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home.
另外，我有一个 19 岁的男孩，也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会把我们吃掉。
And he loves this stuff.
他喜欢这个东西。
It's so great, I'm very grateful we got, we got to sample this, my son is gonna eat it all, I'm gonna have like none of it.
太棒了，我很感激我们得到了它，我们必须品尝这个，我儿子会把它全部吃掉，而我却什么都不吃。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds, doing school drop off, just trying to finish your to-do list, take a moment to save or something delicious for you or your children.
但没关系，它是一种适合你一天的零食，无论你是在赶会议还是喂婴儿或 19 岁的孩子，放学，只是想完成你的待办事项清单，花点时间为你或你的孩子存钱或吃点美味的东西。
And did we mention they're portable toss a few in your glove box or gym bag the diaper bag wherever we have a diaper bag I bet you do Two or three of those bad boys Pick up a pack today your local grocer or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast use code mother 10 Mother one zero at check out for 10% off your first order the very and meet snack sticks great taste zero sugar Josh yeah, like you have a new baby a new child.
我们是否提到过它们是便携式的，在您的手套箱或健身包中扔一些在尿布袋中，无论我们有尿布袋，我敢打赌，您会做两个或三个坏男孩今天拿起一包，您当地的杂货店或在 bavarianmeats.com 进货斜线播客使用代码母亲 10 母亲在结账时享受 10% 折扣，非常和满足零食棒味道好零糖乔希是的，就像你有一个新婴儿一个新孩子一样。
He's not so new, nine months.
他不那么新了，才九个月。
Is that new?
那是新的吗？
That's not that new actually.
这其实并不新鲜。
So how have you started keeping track of his spending?
那么你是如何开始跟踪他的支出的呢？
What we're spending on him or what he personally is spending?
我们在他身上花了什么，或者他个人在花什么？
What he personally is charging at the at the at the local convenience shop at the at the five and dime.
他个人在当地便利店的收费是五毛钱。
Yeah, we we decided it's not safe to give him money because he would like he does with everything else we had.
是的，我们认为给他钱是不安全的，因为他希望用我们拥有的其他东西来做。
He would eat it.
他会吃掉它。
He didn't put it in his mouth and you know money and coins It's not what you want your baby eating so we're we're keeping them off the money train for just a bit longer But I imagine you have teenagers, right?
他没有把它放进嘴里，你知道钱和硬币这不是你想让你的宝宝吃的东西，所以我们要让他们远离金钱火车一段时间但我想你有青少年，对吧？
So you're you're probably in the thick of the money game with them, right?
那么你可能正与他们陷入激烈的金钱游戏，对吗？
I absolutely am and now that their money basically exists in the Netherworld of Telephone version.
我绝对是，现在他们的钱基本上存在于电话版本的幽冥世界中。
There's no I don't know so cash right used to be you give your cave cash Tell them to run down to the chocolate shop pick you up a an egg cream Yeah, you have no idea what this money is being spent on but there's a solution for that What's that?
没有，我不知道，所以现金过去就是你给你的洞穴现金告诉他们跑到巧克力店给你买一个鸡蛋奶油是的，你不知道这些钱花在什么地方，但有一个解决方案那是什么？
Well, for all the parents out there were teenagers We know you're already trying to keep a million different things under control Cash app is here to help make sure your teens money and their spending is an adding to that craziness By sponsoring your teen age 13 to 17 they can get a custom cash app card set personal savings goals and even earn interest on savings with zero monthly fees no minimum balance and complete oversight from your account new cash app customers can earn ten dollars if they use code family ten in their profile at signup and send five dollars to a friend within fourteen days terms apply cash app is a financial services platform, not a bank.
好吧，对于所有青少年的父母来说，我们知道您已经在努力控制一百万种不同的事情现金应用程序可以帮助确保您的青少年有钱，他们的支出会加剧这种疯狂通过赞助您的 13 至 17 岁青少年，他们可以获得一张定制的现金应用程序卡，设置个人储蓄目标，甚至可以赚取储蓄利息，每月费用为零，没有最低余额，并由您的帐户进行完全监督，如果新的现金应用程序客户在注册并发送时使用代码系列 10，则可以赚取 10 美元十四天内给朋友五美元申请现金条款应用程序是一个金融服务平台，而不是银行。
Banking services provided by cashapps bank partners.
由 cashapps 银行合作伙伴提供的银行服务。
Prepaid debit cards issued by Sutton bank, member FDIC, cashapp visa, debit flex cards issued by Sutton bank, member FDIC, and the bank core bank NA.
Sutton 银行、FDIC 成员发行的预付借记卡、cashapp Visa、Sutton 银行、FDIC 成员和银行核心银行 NA 发行的灵活借记卡。
Pursuant to a license from Visa USA Incorporated.
根据 Visa USA Incorporated 的许可。
C terms and conditions for the Sutton prepaid card, Sutton debit flex card, and bank core debit flex card.
适用于 Sutton 预付卡、Sutton 借记灵活卡和银行核心借记灵活卡的 C 条款和条件。
Savings provided by CashApp, a block-incorporated brand.
由 Block-incorporated 品牌 CashApp 提供的节省。
Visit cash.app-legal-slash-podcast for full disclosures.
请访问 cash.app-legal-slash-podcast 了解完整披露信息。
Hey, Alex!
嘿，亚历克斯！
Remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about.
你知道我正在谈论的那个人。
The red, white, and blue ones.
有红的、白的、蓝的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
They pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds.
他们几乎统治着附近的游泳池和游乐场。
Your face should be covered with your finger.
你的脸应该用手指遮住。
It was just a delightful summer memory.
这只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
Well, five-hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and re-imagined it as a bold, refreshing, fireworks-freez energy shot.
嗯，五小时能量消除了这种标志性的怀旧情绪，并将其重新想象为大胆、清爽、没有烟火的能量镜头。
Every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion like the original pops of which you speak, expertly blending juicy cherry, citrusy lime, and sweet blue raspberry.
每一口都能带来巨大的风味爆炸，就像您所说的原始流行音乐一样，巧妙地混合了多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜蓝覆盆子。
to completely ignite your taste buds.
彻底点燃你的味蕾。
It's that fruity taste that you crave, created with zero sugar, so you can enjoy the full experience, guilt-free.
这是您渴望的果香味道，采用零糖打造，让您可以无负罪感地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, headed out on a weekend road trip or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation, this portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决午后在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味，这款便携式镜头都是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouth-watering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework freeze flavored five hour energy shot now available online at five hour energy dot com or Amazon.
烟花冷冻口味的五小时能量饮料点燃您的味蕾，现在可在五小时能量网站或亚马逊上购买。
So so you you have this internship you guys connect comedically your whole senior year did you did you start writing comedy together?
所以你们有这个实习机会，你们在整个大四的时候都把喜剧联系在一起，你们开始一起写喜剧了吗？
Yeah, that was where we we dove in like it was I think we were both sort of looking down the barrel of like, you know, what are we going to do after we graduate and it was this is in the golden age of like like Anderson consulting, like everyone was going into consulting firms.
是的，这就是我们投入的地方，我想我们都在低头思考，你知道，我们毕业后要做什么，这是安德森咨询的黄金时代，就像每个人都进入咨询公司一样。
Like there's all these consulting firms and it was sort of like, is that I guess it was sort of like the job for like if you have a bachelor's degree and you have no idea what you're going to do, just go into consulting.
就像有所有这些咨询公司一样，我想这有点像如果你拥有学士学位并且你不知道自己要做什么，就进入咨询行业的工作。
Yeah.
是的。
And other than that, it was like I had no idea.
除此之外，我好像一无所知。
And then Craig and I went to did this internship at MTV and saw how TV is made and realized like, oh, we love writing.
然后克雷格和我去 MTV 实习，看到了电视是如何制作和实现的，就像，哦，我们喜欢写作。
And here's a job because I, and I psychoanalyzed myself about this a lot.
这是一份工作，因为我对自己进行了很多心理分析。
My dad was a lawyer and he grew grew up sort of putting on a suit every day and going to work with this briefcase and coming home.
我父亲是一名律师，他从小就每天穿着西装，带着公文包去上班，然后回家。
And no one ever modeled the Bohemian life for me.
没有人为我塑造波西米亚生活。
Lovey Bohem, you know, in no sense of like, oh, this is how to be an artist.
Lovey Bohem，你知道，绝不是，哦，这就是成为一名艺术家的方式。
This is like how to, so in my mind it was like, I wanna be an artist, but like when I'm a grownup, I'm gonna have to have a job with an office, with a desk that I sit at where I do my job and then come home, like, and there's no- Come home exhausted and depleted.
这就像如何，所以在我看来，就像，我想成为一名艺术家，但就像当我长大后，我必须找到一份有办公室的工作，有一张办公桌，我坐在我工作的地方，然后回家，就像，没有-回家时筋疲力尽。
Yeah, come home exhausted and depleted and quietly stare into the fire, drinking gin, which my dad did not do.
是的，疲惫不堪地回到家，静静地盯着火，喝着杜松子酒，而我爸爸却没有这样做。
That was just me.
那只是我。
I have, like, that's kind of what I'm crying right now, personally.
我个人来说，这就是我现在哭泣的原因。
No, but seeing TV, it was like, oh, here's a thing where like you're writing, but like all the things that are bad about writing, like the uncertainty of where you're gonna do it.
不，但是看电视，就像，哦，这是你正在写作的事情，但就像所有写作不好的事情一样，比如你要在哪里做的不确定性。
Well, that's taken care of because you have an office and the loneliness of like writing is just sitting in a room doing that And then like you find out like, oh TV shows are written by like a bunch of idiots sitting around a table, just like I sit around a table at a diner with my friends, just goofing around.
嗯，这个问题已经解决了，因为你有一间办公室，而写作的孤独感就只是坐在一个房间里做，然后你会发现，哦，电视节目是由一群白痴围坐在桌子旁写的，就像我和朋友们围坐在餐馆的桌子旁，只是闲逛。
That's how TV is made.
电视就是这样制作的。
I mean, and I think Craig felt the same way and we were sort of like, all right, this is, if nothing else, like this is one thing that we can do, you know, after June, 1997 that.
我的意思是，我认为克雷格也有同样的感觉，我们有点像，好吧，如果没有别的，这就是我们可以做的一件事，你知道，在 1997 年 6 月之后。
I've never thought about it exactly this way, but just because of exactly how you just said that Carter, I did see love Vibo M in a way, because my dad was an advertising copywriter, like a madman-era advertising copywriter.
我从来没有这样想过，但正是因为你刚才卡特的说法，我确实在某种程度上看到了对Vibo M的爱，因为我的父亲是一个广告文案，就像一个疯子时代的广告文案。
And the funny thing is, I watched him come home at night, be so stressed out by writing deadlines that he chained, smoked, and drank vodka, tonics, and was kind of miserable a great deal of time.
有趣的是，我看到他晚上回家，因为写最后期限而感到压力很大，他被锁链锁着，抽烟，喝伏特加和补品，很多时候都很痛苦。
And I went, I want to do that.
我去了，我想这么做。
That's me.
这就是我。
That is the key to longevity and happiness.
这是长寿和幸福的关键。
I'm going down that path.
我正沿着那条路走下去。
So I had a little hint that people wrote things and got paid for it.
所以我有一点暗示，人们写东西并为此获得报酬。
So I had a little head start on knowing that was a thing, although it was ads, it was commercials and print ads and stuff.
所以我先一步知道这是一件事，虽然它是广告，但它是商业广告和平面广告之类的东西。
my dad was brilliant at it.
我父亲在这方面非常出色。
But I, but yeah, I'm like I who like watched Barton think, which is essentially a study like in hell via through the, you know, it was through the lens of writer, like being literally in development hell and I went, that seems fun.
但是我，但是，是的，我就像我一样喜欢看巴顿的思考，这本质上是一项像地狱一样的研究，通过，你知道，这是通过作家的镜头，就像字面意义上的发展地狱一样，我去了，这看起来很有趣。
I just kept like the punishment of it.
我只是一直喜欢惩罚而已。
I want it or something, but I think the thing, the thing that sparked for me when you were saying that Surrey Carter is, you made it, I think the part I was scared about was the loneliness because my dad alone in a room really doing everything kind of for his agency was like the creative director, he was like the soul showrunner.
我想要它什么的，但我认为，当你说萨里·卡特是你做到了的时候，那件事激发了我，我认为我害怕的部分是孤独，因为我父亲独自一人在一个房间里，真正为他的机构做着一切，就像创意总监，他就像灵魂剧主持人。
I'm getting to make stuff up with you, like really having a partner, really helped me so much, I think, because I was scared of that part of it, the kind of loneliness, and having my dad just seemed lonely in their writing every night.
我开始和你和好，就像真的有一个伴侣，这对我帮助很大，我想，因为我害怕那部分，那种孤独，而我爸爸每天晚上在他们的写作中显得孤独。
They was really good at it, but there are ways in which writing, even in a partnership, we would divvy up our tasks.
他们确实很擅长写作，但即使是在合作伙伴关系中，我们也可以通过多种方式来分配我们的任务。
Even I, we would each go right and you wanted that time, but having a partner to figure it out with at the beginning meant everything to me.
即使是我，我们都会走对路，你想要那个时间，但在一开始就有一个合作伙伴来解决这个问题对我来说意味着一切。
And I think got me over the fear of like, the part that seemed scariest for my dad, which was being alone.
我认为这让我克服了对我父亲来说最可怕的恐惧，那就是孤独。
And in a kind of meta way, I mean, you guys ended up creating a show that was about people finding community and a hedge against loneliness, going through the tough times together.
我的意思是，以某种元的方式，你们最终创作了一部关于人们寻找社区和对抗孤独、共同度过艰难时期的节目。
I have to say, Carter, when you described your dad and the suit and the lawyer, maybe it's a Ohio thing, not everyone in Ohio is a lawyer, but it was the exact same thing.
我不得不说，卡特，当你描述你的父亲、诉讼和律师时，也许这是俄亥俄州的事情，不是俄亥俄州的每个人都是律师，但这是完全相同的事情。
I thought, I just don't wanna wear a tie to my job.
我想，我只是不想在工作中打领带。
If I can just create a job where I don't have to wear a tie, I like ties, special occasions, but I don't want to wear one every day.
如果我能创造一份不必打领带的工作，我喜欢打领带，喜欢特殊场合，但我不想每天都打领带。
So when I discovered the theater and I saw adults, you know, that made plays for a living and I just thought, get me in there.
因此，当我发现剧院并看到以戏剧为生的成年人时，我就想，让我进去吧。
Yeah.
是的。
It's funny to say ties because I feel like there's so much, there's so much of that in like, especially like, like, okay, so like Barney, we're jumping all over the place here.
说领带很有趣，因为我觉得有很多，有很多这样的东西，特别是像，像，好吧，就像巴尼一样，我们在这里到处跳跃。
But like Barney's obsession with suits, like, I feel, I absolutely feel like that comes from some, some deep dark place that we probably all connect with generation of like data that's going out putting on suits, you know, the huge movie for me was The Commitments, which was like, you know, the, the movie about the, the Dublin Soul Band, the, the guys that started Soul Band in Dublin and Craig and I started a Soul Band in, in, in, in, uh, the middle tech, which was probably somewhat inspired by that.
但就像巴尼对西装的痴迷一样，我觉得，我绝对觉得这来自于某个、某个深深的黑暗地方，我们可能都与穿着西装的类似数据的产生有关，你知道，对我来说一部大电影是《承诺》，这就像，你知道，这部电影是关于都柏林灵魂乐队的电影，那些在都柏林和克雷格创立了灵魂乐队的人，我在，在，在，在，呃，中间技术，可能是受此启发的。
And part of the whole thing was, you know, they wear suits.
整个事情的一部分是，你知道，他们穿西装。
And like, they have a whole discussion in the movie about like, oh, you got to put on a suit because suit makes you play better.
就像，他们在电影中进行了一次完整的讨论，比如，哦，你必须穿上西装，因为西装让你打得更好。
You play better in your suit.
穿上你的套装你会打得更好。
And like, the idea of a suit as something you wear recreationally as something you put on because you want to.
就像，西装是你休闲时穿的东西，是你因为想要穿而穿的东西。
That was, that was the, I think that was the key to Barney.
那是，那是，我认为那是巴尼的关键。
It was like, he's not like, you know, because he was like, I saw my, my dad, you know, he retired and was like, I'm never putting on a suit again.
就像，他不像，你知道，因为他就像，我看到了我的，我的父亲，你知道，他退休了，然后就像，我再也不会穿西装了。
And like, I don't they have seen Oh my God.
就像，我不知道他们看过《天哪》。
This is really, really hard to see since then.
从那时起，这真的很难看到。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Same.
相同的。
So like the, it's sort of like the, the finding the spirit of like, I'm seizing control of this.
所以就像，有点像，找到类似的精神，我正在控制这件事。
I'm wearing the suit by choice.
我选择穿这套衣服。
I think that's so interesting.
我觉得这很有趣。
There is a connection between us putting on those suits in the soul band in Wesleyan when we were 19 and 20 and Barney.
当我们 19 岁和 20 岁的时候，我们在卫斯理安灵魂乐队中穿上这些套装和巴尼之间存在着某种联系。
There's a literal, there's a straight line between the idea of choosing your own suit destiny.
从字面上看，选择自己的西装命运的想法之间有一条直线。
Yeah.
是的。
I never thought of that.
我从来没有想过这一点。
And there was absolutely a sort of we did sort of the experimental anthropology of seeing what it's like to walk around in a suit, especially on a college campus, especially campus like Wesleyan that's like, you know, just a bunch of hippies and stuff, but like walking around in a suit like you do realize like, oh, I'm radiating this weird power that I think I have.
我们确实做了某种实验人类学，看看穿着西装走来走去是什么感觉，特别是在大学校园，尤其是像卫斯理安这样的校园，你知道，只是一群嬉皮士之类的东西，但就像穿着西装走来走去，就像你意识到的那样，哦，我散发着我认为我拥有的这种奇怪的力量。
I'm making each one of these kids think of their dad.
我让这些孩子中的每一个都想起他们的父亲。
They're all thinking of their dad who disappointed that they didn't get get into Harvard and, and what do you study?
他们都在想他们的父亲，他对他们没有进入哈佛感到失望，而你学什么？
Like, why are you crying again?
比如，你怎么又哭了？
And, but like, there was a, yeah, there was a power in wearing the suit.
而且，但是就像，是的，穿着这套西装有一种力量。
And I, it's kind of like how Barney ended up in a suit.
而我，这有点像巴尼最终穿上了西装。
Oh, man.
哦，伙计。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Paul Feeig says that you, they'll let you in anywhere if you're carrying a clipboard.
保罗·费格说，如果你携带写字板，他们就会让你进入任何地方。
Like, you get on in any building in the world, and they'll just, yeah, if you have a laminated thing, a laminated necklace, you can walk right into the Oval Office just for now.
就像，你在世界上任何一栋大楼里，他们都会说，是的，如果你有层压的东西，层压的项链，你现在就可以直接走进椭圆形办公室。
It's also just funny where you're like, I'm not wearing this unless it's semi-ironic.
这也很有趣，你会说，我不会穿这个，除非它是半讽刺的。
Okay, I have to be a control of when and how I'm putting on this.
好吧，我必须控制何时以及如何穿上它。
And to be clear, our suits in that band were like from the ladies auxiliary theft store and middle of that Connecticut.
需要明确的是，我们那个乐队的套装就像来自康涅狄格州中部的女士辅助防盗店。
And my mind was red, except the red blazer didn't quite match the red pants.
我的想法是红色的，除了红色西装外套与红色裤子不太匹配。
Look at the difference.
看看区别。
Two different rides like Barney would have been like, what in the name of the two red suits?
像巴尼这样的两种不同的游乐设施会是什么样子，两套红色套装的名字是什么？
Yeah.
是的。
Two red suits.
两套红色西装。
They were somewhat similar and I was like sold.
他们有点相似，我就像被卖掉了。
I've got $3 and I'm looking to spend it.
我有 3 美元，我想花掉它。
Okay.
好的。
So you guys, you're senior year, you, you create enough comedy that you have this comedy packet enough to write, send it out to agents and this is a good chance to give a shout out to somebody who, so you remember those people and you've had them too, Josh, where the person that kind of changed your life, right, Carter, this, this executive in MTV, we were there getting him coffee and getting sushi and making photo copies.
所以你们，你们已经是大四了，你们创造了足够多的喜剧，你们有足够的喜剧包来写，把它寄给经纪人，这是一个向某人大声喊叫的好机会，所以你们记得那些人，你们也有过他们，乔什，那个改变了你们生活的人，对吧，卡特，这个，MTV 的这位高管，我们在那里给他喝咖啡，买寿司，复印照片。
And we were writing our little comedy ideas.
我们正在写我们的喜剧小创意。
We were just like we had been in a band and we started writing and comedy together because we clicked so much.
我们就像是在一个乐队里一样，我们开始一起写作和喜剧，因为我们太合拍了。
We started writing our own ideas and submitting it to this executive, this guy Jeremiah Boschang, who's been executive at NBC, he had worked on Seinfeld and now he's in MTV.
我们开始写下自己的想法，并将其提交给这位高管，Jeremiah Boschang，他曾担任 NBC 的高管，曾参与《宋飞正传》的工作，现在在 MTV 工作。
And he saw our little ideas and thought there were clever and interesting enough that he submitted, he, I think, submitted them for us Carter and maybe gave us permission to connect it.
他看到了我们的小想法，认为这些想法足够聪明和有趣，所以他提交了，我认为，他为我们卡特提交了这些想法，也许还允许我们将其连接起来。
No, he gave us the, it was, I mean, this is how I, like people, I'm sure people ask you like, how do you get your start?
不，他给了我们，我的意思是，这就是我喜欢人们的方式，我确信人们会问你，你是如何开始的？
and it's like, our start is so not connected with anything in 2025.
就好像，我们的开始与 2025 年的任何事情都没有关系。
Like it's so old school.
就像它是如此古老的学校一样。
He literally was like send a packet of material with a cover letter that you print out and put in the mail.
他实际上就像发送一包带有求职信的材料，您将其打印出来并放入邮件中。
And in the cover letter mentioned my name in the first sentence.
并且在求职信的第一句话中提到了我的名字。
And that was like all the, like that was the little, like just tights, Gossam or Thin filament of like connection to like if he doesn't read that first sentence, then it goes on some, it goes in the fire and that's it.
这就像所有的，就像那是小，就像紧身衣，棉布或细丝一样，如果他不读第一句话，那么它会继续下去，它会进入火中，就是这样。
There wasn't really email, right?
确实没有电子邮件，对吧？
There was like, yeah, we were still in the era where you went to the science center in college to send an email.
就像，是的，我们仍然处于你去大学科学中心发送电子邮件的时代。
I've gotta go to the science center to send out this message.
我得去科学中心发出这个消息。
I did try to do snow.
我确实尝试过下雪。
We found a thousand years old in this entire, the theme of this whole episode is we were so fucking old.
我们发现这整集已经有一千年了，整集的主题是我们他妈太老了。
That's the theme of this entire thing so far.
这就是到目前为止整件事的主题。
But somehow that worked out and by that guy believing in us, it got to an agent, an agency who was one of the partners there, this guy, Elliott Webb, was Broder, Kirland Webb, offener, I think.
但不知何故，这件事成功了，通过那个相信我们的人，它到达了一个特工，一个机构，他是那里的合作伙伴之一，这个人，埃利奥特·韦伯，是布罗德，基兰·韦伯，我认为是罪犯。
And he was like, I'm a partner, I'm too big for this thing, but they seem clever and they seem, I like this guy Jeremiah, so he gave it to literally the guy who became our agent and is our agent to this day, Matt Rice.
他说，我是一个合伙人，我对这件事太大了，但他们看起来很聪明，而且他们似乎，我喜欢耶利米这个人，所以他把它交给了后来成为我们经纪人、至今仍是我们经纪人的马特·赖斯(Matt Rice)。
So again, our story is useless to anyone, because number one, it sounds ancient and also number two, it's impossible.
再说一次，我们的故事对任何人都没用，因为第一，它听起来很古老，第二，它是不可能的。
That should not have worked.
那不应该起作用。
We sent out one thing, the guy actually gave it to a junior agent who became roasted to ranks Matt Rice as like a big powerful agent and well deservedly so.
我们发出了一件事，那家伙实际上把它交给了一名初级特工，他被炒作了马特·赖斯（Matt Rice），就像一个强大的特工，这是当之无愧的。
He's amazing.
他太棒了。
Just start.
就开始吧。
I mean, he just started.
我的意思是，他才刚刚开始。
He was a little busy at this point.
此时他有点忙。
Yeah, I think.
是的，我想。
Yeah.
是的。
He was like five or six.
他大约五六岁。
Were you guys like kind of his first clients?
你们是他的第一批客户吗？
No, but you know who was?
不，但你知道是谁吗？
Will Forte and Chris Miller and Phil Lord were among his first clients.
威尔·福特、克里斯·米勒和菲尔·洛德是他的第一批客户。
They was like, we were a few in past them.
他们就像是，我们比他们早了一些。
So that's how good this guy is.
所以说这个人的素质就这么好。
And like being a good agent really, there really is a like instinctual super power spidey sense thing that happens in the hazard.
就像真正成为一名优秀特工一样，在危险中确实会发生一种本能的超能力蜘蛛侠感觉。
And we were, so we were in great company.
我们确实如此，所以我们是很好的伙伴。
right away, and Matt Rice helped us get to who was our manager at the time, David Miner, all kind of toward the end and coming out of college, and that somehow led to us getting our Letterman material, we'd written some Conan in material, we'd written a Seinfeld, we'd written SNL ideas, but Letterman was hiring.
马上，马特·赖斯（Matt Rice）帮助我们找到了当时的经理大卫·迈纳（David Miner），一切都快要结束了，即将大学毕业，这不知何故导致我们得到了莱特曼的材料，我们在材料中写了一些柯南，我们写了宋飞传，我们写了《周六夜现场》的想法，但莱特曼正在招聘。
Like, Conan was like, we were obsessed with our dream of Conan.
就像柯南一样，我们沉迷于柯南的梦想。
That was the thing that's part of it also, was like, we want to live in New York, neither of us had any interest in going to LA, and so that really at the time, it was SNL Conan Letterman.
这也是其中的一部分，就像我们想住在纽约，我们都没有兴趣去洛杉矶，所以当时确实是 SNL 柯南莱特曼。
Daily show, the Daily Show, I think maybe the Craig Killborn Daily Show may have existed.
每日秀，每日秀，我想也许克雷格·基尔伯恩每日秀可能已经存在。
But I don't think we were, we were, yeah, we weren't trying that, but yeah.
但我不认为我们是，我们是，是的，我们没有尝试那样，但是是的。
But it was like there's four jobs for comedy writers in, in New York in, in 1997.
但 1997 年的纽约，喜剧作家似乎有四份工作。
And we were obsessed with Conan.
我们对柯南很着迷。
It was like the year of like, where like Robert Smigel was running it and it was just like going bananas and just like every, like it was, it was, it was definitely like, if I, if I'm If I'm going to do anything for living, I want to, I want to write this dumb stuff.
就像那一年，罗伯特·斯密格尔（Robert Smigel）在经营它，就像发疯一样，就像过去一样，过去，过去，绝对是这样，如果我，如果我要为生活做任何事，我想，我想写这些愚蠢的东西。
It was definitely the weirdest thing happening on TV.
这绝对是电视上发生的最奇怪的事情。
It was.
是的。
It was like very strange.
感觉很奇怪。
Like, yeah.
就像，是的。
Can I just push back on your, on, on your path to success a little bit as a thing that isn't repeatable?
我可以在你的成功之路上稍微推迟一下，因为这是一件不可重复的事情吗？
Uh, another way I, I, I think I'll look at it and I'll try to use Letterman's nephew.
呃，换个方式，我，我，我想我会看看它，我会尝试使用莱特曼的侄子。
Okay.
好的。
Well, don't talk about that.
好吧，不谈这个了。
You swore.
你发誓。
Well, isn't exactly the way that you make it.
嗯，这不完全是你的做法。
You do the best that you can up until this one magical line, and you have to do the absolute best you can be incredibly talented, put in a huge amount of work.
在这一条神奇的线路之前，你会尽你所能，你必须尽最大努力，你才能拥有令人难以置信的天赋，投入大量的工作。
And for sure.
当然。
That's all you can do.
这就是你所能做的。
And then on the other side of the line is a whole series of luck, always, but that luck is because you've you've walked up to the door with the right materials and the right person open it.
然后，在这条线的另一边，总是有一系列的运气，但这种运气是因为你已经带着正确的材料走到了门口，并且正确的人打开了它。
That's exactly the way it works, but we did work really hard.
这就是它的运作方式，但我们确实非常努力。
I'll give us that because Carter and I were that whole summer.
我会给我们这个，因为卡特和我整个夏天都在。
You're recording music in my mom's basement while also writing like three portfolios, right?
你在我妈妈的地下室里录制音乐，同时也写三个作品集，对吧？
Like Conan, like Letterman and like Letterman was like the least flushed out.
和柯南一样，和莱特曼一样，和莱特曼一样，他是最不脸红的。
Well, that was the most exciting.
嗯，那是最令人兴奋的。
I was almost like, well, Alex Point.
我几乎就像，好吧，亚历克斯·波因特。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, we spent the whole year working on our Conan packet because it was like, it's gotta be Conan.
我的意思是，我们花了整整一年的时间来制作柯南数据包，因为它就像，它必须是柯南。
Just Conan or nothing.
只有柯南或者什么都没有。
Yeah.
是的。
You loved Letterman.
你爱莱特曼。
I had not watched a lot of Letterman.
我没看过太多莱特曼。
I was like, I was not a Letterman guy necessarily, but then like David Meiner, who Matt hooked us up with, who gets, you know, he's, we have him to thank for our career, for sure.
我当时想，我不一定是莱特曼的人，但就像马特把我们联系起来的大卫·梅纳一样，他得到了，你知道，他，我们的职业生涯肯定要感谢他。
David Miner was like, he basically gave us the news, like, they're not hiring it Conan.
大卫·迈纳说，他基本上给了我们这个消息，就像，他们不会雇用柯南。
Everyone loves it there, obviously, because why would you ever quit this amazing fun show?
显然，每个人都喜欢那里，因为你为什么要退出这个精彩有趣的节目呢？
But two writers had just left Letterman and they were hiring and they're looking for people.
但两位作家刚刚离开莱特曼，他们正在招聘和寻找人才。
And it was, this is like on a Friday and it was like, can you get them a Letterman packet by Monday?
就像是在周五，你能在周一之前给他们寄来莱特曼包裹吗？
And we had a little bit of a start on it, but it was like maybe 20, 30% we just stayed up clear.
我们有一点开始，但大概有 20%、30% 我们只是保持清醒。
I don't show needed a different packet like tonally because they were different.
我没有表现出需要像音调那样的不同数据包，因为它们是不同的。
So a Conan has to be different than a letterman.
所以柯南必须不同于作家。
Especially because Letterman is so like about his voice and about his like specific thing that he does.
尤其是因为莱特曼非常喜欢他的声音和他所做的具体事情。
You had 72 hours to write an enormous amount of comedic material in the voice and style of David Letterman.
你有 72 个小时的时间，用大卫·莱特曼的声音和风格写了大量的喜剧材料。
While living at my mother's house in Long Island.
住在长岛我母亲的家里时。
Yeah.
是的。
And but it's funny.
但这很有趣。
We were like, yeah, we like go to a diner and like thank you know and by the way Jane Thomas I owe her my life as well because she'd like put me up for that that summer like I was like living in Craig's house.
我们说，是的，我们喜欢去一家餐馆，谢谢你知道，顺便说一句，简·托马斯（Jane Thomas）我也欠她一条命，因为她希望那个夏天让我接受，就像我住在克雷格的房子里一样。
How come in my mother?
我妈怎么进来了？
But I just remember like the the there was a moment of that we had to push through but a moment of like we just spent nine months on this Conan O'Brien packet and you're telling us we have to generate a top 10 list and we only have two days to do it that's outrageous.
但我只记得有那么一刻我们必须坚持下去，但有那么一刻我们刚刚花了九个月的时间在这个柯南·奥布莱恩的包上，你告诉我们我们必须生成一个前十名的列表，而我们只有两天的时间来做这件事，这太离谱了。
And like, you know, the joke being to write a top 10 list, you have like three hours to do it when you get the job.
就像，你知道，一个笑话是写一份前十名的清单，当你得到这份工作时，你有大约三个小时的时间来完成它。
So like, yeah, I'm a way to done.
就像，是的，我是一种完成方式。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
But yeah, we, that was a, it was a very long weekend, but ultimately a successful one.
但是，是的，我们，那是一个非常长的周末，但最终是一个成功的周末。
So you get the packet into them by Monday.
所以你可以在周一之前把包裹寄给他们。
When do you hear that you're hired?
你什么时候听说你被录用了？
Like the next few days into that week, our lives change, our lives change, like what, like maybe the next week after that, we started a card or it was like, it was so fast.
就像那一周的接下来几天，我们的生活发生了变化，我们的生活发生了变化，就像之后的下周，我们开始一张卡片，或者就像，它太快了。
Yeah, we had like a we did one interview with Tim Long who was the head writer and then shout out to Tim as well.
是的，我们对首席作家蒂姆·朗进行了一次采访，然后也向蒂姆大喊大叫。
Shout out to Tim and Kate Adler who was the producer at the time and she the two of them sort of bumped us up to the next and then the second interview was on the 12th floor which I think we didn't we didn't understand the meaning of that at the time but in the letterman days the 12th floor was Dave's floor like that's that's like the that's like the main production floor of Letterman, and it was with Robert Net, the executive producer at the time, and Rob, you know, we file in, we go up the elevator to this, and it's not a big, it's not like a labyrinth, it's like an L-shape of the floor plan of the 12th floor, but we go in, and he's down at one end, and we go into Rob's office, and I remember Rob, this is how young we were, we had our resumes attached to the thing.
向蒂姆和凯特·阿德勒致敬，他们当时是制片人，他们两个把我们推到了下一个，然后第二次采访是在 12 楼，我想我们当时不明白这意味着什么，但在莱特曼时代，12 楼是戴夫的楼层，就像莱特曼的主要制作楼层一样，是和当时的执行制片人罗伯特·奈特一起进行的，罗布，你知道，我们鱼贯而入，乘电梯到这里，它并不大，不像迷宫，就像12楼平面图的L形，但我们进去了，他在一端，我们进入罗布的办公室，我记得罗布，我们当时多么年轻，我们把简历贴在这东西上。
And they were like, and I remember rubbing like, well, their grades are really good.
我记得他们的反应是，好吧，他们的成绩真的很好。
We had a GPA.
我们有平均绩点（GPA）。
But yeah, in that moment, he was like, the month in October.
但是，是的，在那一刻，他就像是十月。
Not bad.
不错。
No CPR.
没有心肺复苏。
Okay.
好的。
I don't know CPR.
我不懂心肺复苏术。
But that was on a Friday.
但那是在星期五。
And he basically said, like, no, they seem good to me.
他基本上说，不，他们对我来说似乎很好。
Then he turned to us and was like, enjoy this weekend.
然后他转向我们说，享受这个周末。
This is as good as this job is going to get, because starting Monday it's going to be terrible, but come in on Monday and you're hired.
这是这份工作所能得到的最好的结果，因为从周一开始，情况会很糟糕，但周一来，你就会被录用。
We walked out and we're so stunned that we got lost in the complex L shape floor plan of the closing.
我们走出去，惊呆了，迷失在复杂的L形平面图中。
No way to get lost, but we got lost.
没办法迷路，但我们迷路了。
All the way down the hall, we turned the only corner, we turned the corner, the only corner of the whole hallway.
沿着走廊一路走下去，我们拐过了唯一的拐角，我们拐过了拐角，整个走廊唯一的拐角。
We turned the corner and you can film this in your mind, it's high noon, and there at the other end is David Letterman.
我们拐过街角，你可以在脑海中拍摄这一幕，当时是正午，而另一端是大卫·莱特曼。
Like standing alone, like, I think he was like tossing a football, just standing there, like he's maybe going to kick our ass or something.
就像独自站着一样，我想他就像扔一个足球，站在那里，好像他可能会踢我们的屁股什么的。
And we say to him, do you know where the elevator is?
我们对他说，你知道电梯在哪里吗？
And he says, yeah, I love, I remember that particular phrasing, do you know where the elevator is?
他说，是的，我喜欢，我记得那个特定的措辞，你知道电梯在哪里吗？
Like this building that has your name on it in giant lights?
喜欢这座用巨型灯光刻有您名字的建筑吗？
Wow.
哇。
You do it.
你做吧。
That's a, that's an incredibly charming story.
这是一个非常迷人的故事。
I love that you guys ran into him and this mythic kind of character.
我喜欢你们遇到他和这个神话般的人物。
And I think we were wearing backpacks.
我想我们都背着背包。
I think we brought back packs and meaning and he called us the backpack boys behind our back for years.
我认为我们带回了背包和意义，多年来他在背后称我们为背包男孩。
Yeah.
是的。
The backpack was our nickname.
背包是我们的昵称。
The worst boy.
最糟糕的男孩。
The worst boy man of all time.
有史以来最糟糕的男孩。
The rough draft is the most be boys.
草稿最多的是男生。
So you guys are there.
所以你们就在那里。
How long six years?
六年有多长？
Four and a half years.
四年半了。
Oh four and a half.
四岁半哦。
Four and a half.
四点半。
Okay.
好的。
The next time we talk today after that story was just one of me said goodbye.
在那个故事之后，我们今天下次谈话时，我中的一个人就说了再见。
We probably talked about three other times in between.
中间我们可能还讨论过三次。
So tell me, what did you guys learn at Letterman that helped you write and run how I made your mother?
那么告诉我，你们在莱特曼学到了什么，帮助你们编写和运行《我创造了你们的母亲》？
Everything, right?
一切，对吧？
Like, everything.
就像，一切。
We were, because after Letterman, we were on a couple of other sitcoms that are sort of forgettable, didn't really go the distance.
我们是，因为在《莱特曼》之后，我们还出演了其他几部有点容易被遗忘的情景喜剧，但并没有真正走下去。
Although we're an American dad, which is still on TV, which is amazing.
虽然我们是美国爸爸，但这仍然在电视上，这太棒了。
We're in there for one season.
我们在那里呆了一个赛季。
But basically, everything we needed to learn to be a showrunner, we learned at Letterman, and then when you go on to a sitcom staff, a lot of the ethos, at least back in the day when we were getting into it, was like, the writers weren't in the edit room.
但基本上，我们在莱特曼学到了成为一名剧集主管所需的一切，然后当你进入情景喜剧工作人员时，很多精神，至少在我们进入它的那天，就像，编剧不在编辑室里。
The writers weren't necessarily always on set.
编剧不一定总是在片场。
The writers sort of wrote things and were that part of the assembly line.
作家们写了一些东西，并且是流水线的一部分。
On Letterman, you had, if you had an idea in the morning, you had to produce it by the showtime, you had to get your music, you had to order up your graphics, you had to, if there was, like, Kyron and titles involved.
在莱特曼，你必须，如果你早上有一个想法，你必须在放映时间之前制作它，你必须获得你的音乐，你必须订购你的图形，你必须，如果涉及到凯伦和标题。
Every piece of it, you went on the shoot, you basically kind of directed or co-directed your bit.
每一个片段，你都参与拍摄，基本上都是你自己导演或共同导演的。
You had it with the director and make sure you got everything you needed.
你和导演商定了，并确保你得到了你需要的一切。
Get into an edit room, book your time there, get with the editor.
进入编辑室，预订时间，与编辑会面。
Like every part of it was you.
就像它的每一部分都是你一样。
Every part of it you were responsible for producing.
它的每个部分都是你负责制作的。
And that was such good training for being a showrunner.
对于成为一名节目主持人来说，这真是一次很好的训练。
Because by the time, I think by the time some writers who've only ever been on sitcom staffs, they become a showrunner.
因为到了那个时候，我认为到了一些只在情景喜剧工作人员中工作过的作家，他们就成为了剧集主管。
They've never really spent a lot of of time in edit, they've never done a sound mix.
他们从未真正花费大量时间进行编辑，也从未进行过混音。
I remember we had done all that stuff.
我记得我们已经做了所有这些事情。
It can't be overstated how much like technology and like the editing software that exists now like I movie coming built into your laptop.
无论如何强调，它与现在存在的技术和编辑软件有多么相似，就像我的电影内置在你的笔记本电脑中一样。
How much that has changed the world?
这给世界带来了多大改变？
Because at the time it really was like us knowing how to go into an edit room was like we'd gone to Hogwarts.
因为当时我们知道如何进入编辑室就像我们去了霍格沃茨一样。
Like we like had this like mystical power that like like really like no one understood how to like, you know trim 15 frames off of something.
就像我们喜欢拥有这种神秘的力量一样，就像没有人知道如何喜欢一样，你知道将某些东西剪掉 15 帧。
Like dumb simple stuff that anyone in the world now knows, it was really like that letterman definitely gave us a chance to like basically go to film school for four years, go to film school and comedy school in a big way.
就像现在世界上任何人都知道的愚蠢简单的事情一样，这真的就像莱特曼确实给了我们一个机会，基本上可以去电影学校四年，在很大程度上去电影学校和喜剧学校。
I also feel like the whole like 10,000 hours thing of like learning how to like I definitely feel like I learned how to how to write a joke and how to write something that gets a laugh.
我也觉得整个一万个小时的事情就像学习如何喜欢我绝对觉得我学会了如何写一个笑话以及如何写一些让人发笑的东西。
I don't even think that myself isn't necessarily a funny person, but I knew what the mechanics were of, and the only way to learn that is doing it over and over and failing a lot.
我什至不认为自己不一定是一个有趣的人，但我知道其中的机制是什么，而学习这一点的唯一方法就是一遍又一遍地做，并多次失败。
Yeah, I wanted to ask you about that.
是的，我想问你这个问题。
The failure did it, it did it, thicken your skin considerably, so you pitch jokes, obviously, to these older, more veteran writers, and they're swatting them down, or ideas are getting bad a down or something doesn't get a laugh like did you feel like that which didn't kill you made you stronger kind of by the end of that.
失败做到了，它做到了，让你的脸皮变得厚厚的，所以你显然向这些年长、更有经验的作家开玩笑，他们正在猛烈地打压他们，或者想法变得很糟糕，或者有些事情不会让人笑，就像你觉得那些没有杀死你的东西到最后会让你变得更坚强。
Yeah definitely and it was very humbling and it told you it was a volume business you needed to have an extra you needed to have an next idea there was no there's no writers block when you're doing five shows a week and you're getting paid decent money to do it there's no writer you have to have an idea you have to have an idea and even if it's not great you have to do you have to produce it and make it and hope that it gets on and does okay Carter and I did the viewer male segment for four years of our four and a half years there, and we would go down for the taping of that segment and be in the audience, and you had to sit in that, and we stood up to the side, and we would sit there and listen to those play and either get a laugh from the audience or not get a laugh from the audience, and what didn't get a laugh, and it was dead silent, and Dave's up there, this iconic, wonderful, I mean, I idolized Dave, I loved him, I made that joke before, but I loved Dave.
是的，这确实是非常令人谦卑的，它告诉你，这是一个批量业务，你需要额外的东西，你需要有下一个想法，没有作家的障碍，当你每周做五场演出，而且你得到了可观的钱来做这件事，没有作家，你必须有一个想法，你必须有一个想法，即使它不是很好，你也必须做，你必须制作它并制作它，并希望它能继续下去，做得很好卡特和我做了四个观众的男性部分我们在那四年半的时间里，我们会去录制那个片段，坐在观众席上，你必须坐在那儿，我们站到一边，我们会坐在那里听那些戏剧，要么让观众笑，要么不让观众笑，没有笑的，就一片寂静，戴夫就在那里，这个标志性的，美妙的，我的意思是，我崇拜戴夫，我爱他，我以前开过那个玩笑，但我爱戴夫。
When he would turn on it, he'd go like, Ooh, that was a tough one, Paul.
当他打开它时，他会说，哦，这很难，保罗。
I feel like we were getting torn a new one on national television by our hero, or at least my hero.
我觉得我们的英雄，或者至少是我的英雄，在国家电视台上撕扯了一场新的戏。
And there's nothing more humbling.
没有什么比这更令人谦卑的了。
There's no thicker skin to be developed than that moment.
没有比那一刻更厚的脸皮了。
And you got to scrape yourself off the floor and say, I got at least one more shot at this next week if we don't get fired.
你必须把自己从地板上爬起来，说，如果我们不被解雇的话，下周我至少还有一次机会。
And you just work even harder.
而你只是更加努力地工作。
And you develop that ability to bounce back.
你就会培养出反弹的能力。
New York City!
纽约市！
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Webb 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point de Blue Studios, artwork by John Marrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，作品由 John Marrow 设计。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliot Connards。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的 Dead Father Society。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
I've realized lately that the products I use every single morning genuinely affect how I feel for the rest of the day.
最近我意识到我每天早上使用的产品确实会影响我一天中剩下的时间的感觉。
If something feels heavy, greasy, overly make-up-y or complicated, I just stop reaching for it.
如果某样东西感觉很重、油腻、过度化妆或复杂，我就会停止接触它。
That's why I've been loving Primely Peer's new Sun Serum Tinted SPF.
这就是为什么我一直喜欢 Primely Peer 的新款防晒精华有色 SPF。
It gives mineral SPF-30 protection and enough coverage to make my skin look even and healthy, but it still looks like my skin.
它提供 SPF-30 的矿物质保护和足够的遮盖力，使我的皮肤看起来均匀健康，但它看起来仍然像我的皮肤。
It has this really fresh, lived-in glow, and their lip and cheek tint has become one of those products I keep throwing on throughout the day because it makes me look instantly more awake and put together in like 10 seconds.
它具有真正新鲜、持久的光泽，而且它们的唇部和脸颊色调已成为我整天不断使用的产品之一，因为它让我看起来立即更加清醒，并且在 10 秒钟内就完成了。
The whole vibe just feels very effortless.
整个氛围感觉非常轻松。
Skin first, clean girl beauty, products that enhance your skin.
肌肤第一，干净少女美，提升肌肤品质的产品。
If you've been wanting your routine to feel lighter, simpler and more natural this summer, definitely check out Primely Peer's Sun Serum and Lip and Cheek Tints.
如果您希望今年夏天的日常护理变得更轻松、更简单、更自然，一定要看看 Primely Peer 的防晒精华和唇颊彩。